[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y en a
un score de secours des soins
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame monsieur je suis alain
gouaméné
comment voulez de voir ça trop trop
facile à il arrête le penalty mais d'où
vient toute vient-il s et la question
comment il est arrivé là
un enfant né dans un petit village à 20
km de gagnoa
la seule alternative qui l'avait pour
sortir de ce village c'est de faire des
études
aller à l'école vous connaissez cp1 cp2
aussi mode et avoir entre en 6e surtout
parce qu'on n'a pas l'entrée en sixième
qu'est-ce qu'on devient on devient
planteurs oukil tu vas faire en même
temps parce que nos parents n'avaient
pas l'argent pour les payer les cours en
sixième la scolarité ça c'était terrible
passage je vous parlais cet après midi
comment positiver son stress dans toute
chose j'ai fait une grande école
la grande école pour moi c'est le
football et le football c'est l'école de
la vie et jeunesse
vous avez trouvé dans deux grandes
sociétés vous êtes 1000 ou 2000 dans les
grandes sociétés ou travailler même
n'est pas dire bonjour à son collègue de
travail
c'est pas grave d'autant plus que le
même bureau en beauce nord football
quelqu'un qui tu as pris ta petite
copine est un partenaire de tous les
jours promenade ensemble dîner déjeuner
petit déjeuner déjeuner et dîner
ensemble cohérent des matches ensemble
et il est on taira le droit est ce qu'on
lui donne pas le ballon c'est ça je vous
dis c'est l'école de la vie
il faut faire attention à beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de choses dans la vie
c'est facile mais là c'est compliqué
mais paysans que je t'ai je suis très
heureux d'être là aujourd'hui devant
vous ou par les français au lieu de vous
parler péter j'ai pas envie de parler
moi non c'est pas le problème
le but n'est pas de parler de moi le but
aider comment arriver à ça et j'arrive à
vous vos pneus les parents vos enfants
c'est pas vous qui allez jouer au
football mais c'est vos enfants qui fait
au football alors vous le prenez vous
les enlevez le col ou les amener sur un
terrain de football
il faut qu'ils jouent non il faut faire
des études d'abord et après faire du
football
pourquoi ces 150 élèves dans une classe
il ya au moins la moitié qui ici c'est
quand % sur cent joueurs il ya un seul
tir réussi un pourcentage vraiment
minime si on peut appeler ça pourcentage
alors pour donner plus de chances à nos
enfants
pour avoir ce courage et pouvoir vivre
leur vie première des choses en main et
les à l'école encourage les à réussir à
l'école et vous allez voir
après le foot ça m'est tombé dessus
parce que moi je ne passais pas
footballeur
non je ferai du handball et ça m'est
tombé dessus et j'ai fait du football
mais quand je les fais parce que ça nous
amène la côte à 92 il ya beaucoup tu as
envie d'entendre comment ils ont fait il
paraît que y'avait des sorciers il
paraît qu'il y avait tout non c'est plus
vite non pour vous dire qu'en ce moment
c'est ça vous avez vous voyez que le
ghana en finale mais le plus dur dans no
stress que je vais vous dire de
positiver dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est pas la finale c'est les demi
finales les finales sont simples où tu
gagnes ou tu perds
mais si vous regardez bien le tableau du
football et du sport en général et du
football en particulier
tous les troisièmes les médailles de
bronze sont plus heureux que la médaille
d'argent qu'en donnent les médailles
vous faites pas attention à ça parce que
quand tu as la médaille d'argent c'est
fini tu n'as pas gagné la coupe mais tu
seras toujours le père l'en est en demi
finale quant à la troisième place
tu es heureux dé brandir pas médailles à
la partie n'est que troisième dans les
plus malheureux dans le car et c'est
toujours le 4e et le deuxième sens
et ramènent à la demi finale cette demi
finale contre le cameroun vous rappelez
j'espère aux tirs au but
le stress il n'y est pas encore passé
une demi finale
si tu la perds qu'est ce que tu fais tu
joues le match de classement
mais en côte d'ivoire mon cher pays que
j'aime beaucoup
quand tu gagnes en demi finale que tu je
suis en finale tu es mort c'est juste
une parenthèse des pas mort mais quand
tu reviens on te regarde avec un
environnement savons rien là et quand tu
viens à la médaille de bronze
on dit félicitations donc la demi-finale
sens reims et on la joue le stress c'est
pas le match 10 dont le stress c'est
vous qui donnez le stress oui c'est vous
qui venait dé presse parce que ce qu'on
appelle madame qui est passé tout à
l'heure la répartie quand on fait du
coaching
on apprendra pas toujours un feedback le
fil bac c'est vous au niveau du football
pourquoi au niveau de la station les
fidèles bien et vous parce que après
qu'on ait à l'hôtel qu'on a perdu on a
toutes les informations les journaux qui
nous insultent deux en tête en femme qui
t'appelle pour 10 grammes d'or par
insulter ici tous tes amis
et là tu es mort dans la tête ça c'est
le fils balle de foot alors le stress en
ce moment il est comment il revient à un
niveau très élevé très élevé il
tu dors tu as besoin d'une revanche est
due à la médaille de bronze à jouer donc
encore une chance de relever le défi
mais nous on gagne la demi-finale est on
arrivé en finale
mon pire ennemi je vous le jure de tout
cela la salle ici je veux pas conseillé
ça a amené mon pire ennemi en ce moment
là vous avez dit mais vous l'avez arrêté
non avant avant quand je vous parle de
stress comment possibles sont prescrits
à la peur c'est pas la peur de faire des
dieux on va perdre c'est la peur de ces
que vous vous allez penser le nous et
comme nous avons reçu ce feedback
pendant le match
les 120 minutes on a plus de fraises
parce qu'on joue à une continuité mais
qu'on arrête tout et quand tu penses que
tout un pays hanté tout thème pays
surtout notre pays de football la côte
d'ivoire qui a loupé m'enterrer plus de
dykan avec les grands joueurs comme
laurent pokou paix à son âme aujourd'hui
et toi qui te retrouve là un jeune
paysan qui s'instruit et qui a été dans
le football il a le monopole de mettre
toute la côte d'ivoire à un niveau au
dessus de tout le monde
imaginez un peu ce que c'est et s'auto
l'abbaye
on te dit que le président houphouët
boigny paix à son âme a appelé a
téléphoné et il veut que voulait te
parler
voyez vous je veux souhaiter personnes
c'est je vais jamais jamais plus moi et
heureusement je venais formateurs
décortiquent formateurs des formateurs
mais je souhaite personnes à ce niveau
même si je joue aujourd'hui
et là on nous dit d'aller dans les buts
et on joue contre eux ti vous pour vous
c'est tout juste un pays frontalier
pour nous c'est un ennemi pacifique
le ghana est là je vous le jure
tu n'as plus rien dans le stress que des
passes et comment le positiver on pense
à quoi quand vous êtes stressé ou pensez
quoi
il ya des gens qui pensent à leurs
enfants je pense à leurs épouses
il ya d'autres qui pensent à l'heure
comme vous savez c'est un peu un tout et
moi à ce moment où votre poignet voulait
me parler je pense à quoi j'étais
lessivé fatigué je n'ai raté aucun tir
l'avant bay contre le cameroun janet et
3 hélas rien et j'ai dit je suis mort
mais ce qu'on vous a pas présenté
quand j'ai pas de prince j'ai pensé à
mon épouse mais c'est quand vous avez
présenté c'est quand moi même j'étais
retirer mon penalty
le penalty de côte d'ivoire c'est pas
ton penalty
c'est le penalty de côte d'ivoire et je
vous dis je ne peux parler de moi parce
que j'avais été malade déjà j'ai une
hernie discale
elle cale 5 qui était broyée
pratiquement dont je veux pas jouer du
pied droit à la pêche aux droitiers de
naissance si vous voulez y en avait
encore ses filles nous allons voir que
j'ai tiré avec le pied gauche quels
risques pour notre pays mais j'ai dit je
prie le ballon
j'ai déposé le ballon et je dis embêté
non sérieux tu vas pas rater leur
penalty et ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses ça veut dire beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui on peut en venir
on pensait pas argent là tu penses à la
côte d'ivoire
aucun joueur au monde
aucun joueur au monde footballeur monde
ne pense à son pays
quand on joue personnes
celui qui le dit et vous a menti parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps de penser au pays
qu'on joue pas ce tout en mouvement mais
là ça à l'arrêt le seul moment où on
pense à la côte d'ivoire notre pays
c'est qu'on chante l'hymne national
après ça finit on ne considère plus
c'est bon vous à nous insulter et vous
allez être la réponse est pas bon vous
avez vous insultez là j'étais là je tire
mon penalty
dieu merci je le marque
[Applaudissements]
et à un ouf au seigneur civile qui font
ce qu'ils veulent maintenant moi j'ai
rien à je vous le jure j'ai rien
à le dernier penalty dacca
connais il n'a pas ils ont raté
pratiquement à la prélature ce penalty
et moi quand j allais je n'avais rien à
rattraper non j'étais fatigué lessive et
j'ai pensé à ma petite femme qui était
dans les tribunes on n'avait pas
d'enfants encore son moi et j'ai dit au
fond de moi et je pense aussi à mes
parents parce que on essuie aussi des
parents j'ai dit il faut l'arrêter
je suis là au moins et comme les grands
joueurs ne change jamais leur manière de
tirer le premier l'avait tiré à droite
qui est ce qu'il va mettre à droite si
vous regardez bien il supporte ni même
avant
gêné tir et j'ai à paraître ce penalty
et samara manoury âge où je venais si
moi je le fais ça vos enfants peuvent le
faire ni les plus que par ne les a menés
pas forcément au football laisser l'aiea
les seuls qui aient tout tombe sur eux
mais la seule chose que j ai une dans
tout ça madame monsieur est ce que vous
pouvez comprendre que après cette
compétition cette agitation
c'était fini terminé je me suis
sur le banc de touche tout le monde
courait partout moi j'étais assis là en
face de moi j'avais mon épouse vous
savez ce que je lui ai dit il du moment
mais tout ça à cause de ça parce qu'on
ne savait pas encore c'est que c'est
passé à dijon on ne savait pas encore
c'est que c'est passé un pion de
l'engouement qui avait ici les
débordements le prion qu'il y avait ici
vous même vous l'avez vu je m'appelle
alain gouaméné n'aviez pas et je me
retrouvais dans la même voiture que le
président houphouët boigny
dans vos entreprises d'un beau tout ce
que vous faites dans la vie parce qu'il
ya pas que des entreprises et il ya des
indépendants ne lâche jamais il aura
plusieurs l'adversité
je n'avais aucun talent je n'avais aucun
talent mais j'ai bossé
j'ai tout positiver en tant que j'allais
le faire parce que certains le faisait
déjà
et pourquoi pas moi et en ce moment vous
pouvez arriver
vos enfants s'ils pouvaient arriver
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire cet
après-midi parce que si on rentre dans
les détails
non je pense que personne ne passera
après mois en branle et jusqu'à demain
matin on a été très heureux c'est vrai
mais ce que je retiendrai toujours pour
cette coupe d'afrique est injuste juste
juste le vouloir vouloir et pouvoir
réussir
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]